this course is a detailed Introduction
to System design for software developers
and engineers gorobs then developed this
course he is an experienced software
engineer and he also has a popular
YouTube channel you'll learn about basic
engineering design patterns that are
used to build large-scale distributed
systems in the second part of the course
you will learn how to use the principles
from the first part to design and code a
live streaming video app hello everyone
welcome to the system design course
this course is for beginners in a sense
that if you have never done system
design before or you have done very
little system design or you have just
heard of it or read about it but not got
an opportunity to actually do it this
course is right for you at the end of
this course you'll be able to identify
some basic engineering design patterns
which are used to design large-scale
distributed systems
let me Define each of these terms in
detail large scale distributed systems
as the first part of the term says large
scale meaning that something which is uh
being used a lot or is very intensive in
terms of compute or data or any you know
Computer Engineering principle for
example Google
let's say Google Maps this is large
scale because a it has a lot of data
the whole world's map has to be stored
in inside it uh B it's being used by a
lot of people
seeds being updated very frequently and
D it has a lot of
performance expectations from it you
don't expect Google Maps to go down you
expect Google Maps to return results
quickly you expect it to be accurate so
on and so forth so it's a very good
product being used at a large scale
distributed systems means that the
server or the code that is actually
executing this program is not in one
place it's disputed all around the world
so you might have one server in India
one server in the US One in Japan uh for
fault tolerance so that if one of these
servers crashes the rest of the servers
can take the load uh it's also for
performance if the Indians want a Google
map result they go and talk to the
Indian server because that gives a quick
result back while if they go to the US
server they have to go across continents
and then get a response which is a slow
result
okay so that's the point of a large
scale distributed system many of these
companies which provide these Solutions
expect their Engineers to know about
system design to know how to build these
large-scale distributed systems so to do
this the engineering team depends on
design patterns which we mentioned
earlier design patterns are particular
practices principles or processes which
are used by Engineers to build these
systems for example you have a common
problem of a celebrity posting on social
media and that post being distributed to
a lot of their followers for example if
Brad Pitt posts something on YouTube and
then post it on LinkedIn the problem is
very similar it's one piece of content
which has to be
made into an event and notified to
millions of people potentially and what
you want to do is you want to notify
them quickly but you also don't want to
put too much load on your service so
that the rest of the requests which are
coming into it continue being served
this is a common problem
so you extract out a common problem
and you solve it using a common solution
this would be a design pattern right now
you know you don't know what design
patterns exist but one popular design
pattern for this kind of a problem is a
publisher subscriber model where Brad
Pitt is a publisher and their event is
subscribed to by millions of people
and intermediately decides the pay set
which you send these notifications which
keeps the server load low and also make
sure that all the notifications actually
reach all the subscribers now seeing
this you can tell that as an engineer
you can take a lot of business
requirements and convert them into
Technical Solutions and Engineers use
system design patterns to make reliable
scalable and maintainable systems
this helps them convert business
requirements into Technical Solutions if
this sounds exciting to you watch the
rest of the video and you won't be
disappointed
okay let's start with an example let's
say that you join a company which does
broadcasting of videos to millions of
people this could be hot star it could
be YouTube it could be Zoom also so some
sort of events
which have been broadcast to millions of
people
and you as an engineer have to devise
the solution for this come up with some
technology which can handle this problem
so the first thing that we need to do as
Engineers is to Define these
requirements
from the user's perspective
and often Engineers don't do this they
are product managers in a company which
write a product requirement document
based on user feedback and data so
that's good to have you have
a well-documented well thought uh
business-backed document
which the engineer can then read and
decide on how they can make it happen
amongst these you pick up the most
important features first
taking the example of a live streaming
system users who tune into your system
should be able to watch the stream
Lively
whether you see it at HD quality or you
see it at 480p that's probably a
secondary issue but being able to see
the video is a primary issue so for that
you have to make sure that your server
doesn't go down and you have to also
make sure that your bandwidth
requirements are sufficient second you
reduce these features to data
definitions so one of the features which
might be defined is users should be able
to like our video or should be able to
like a comment
what you then do is you look at the
concept of a like the abstract concept
of somebody liking something what does
that mean it means that a particular
user likes a particular comment okay so
it has a like ID it has a user ID who's
done this it has a timestamp when was
this video liked or when was this
comment liked the comment itself is an
abstract concept it's probably going to
be mapped into an object it has an ID it
has a user who has typed this comment uh
it has a creation time and maybe it also
has a thread in which it was posted
so you're saying that I'm taking
features or I'm taking these abstract
Concepts from the product requirement
document and converting them into Data
definitions
which are useful for an engineer these
definitions can then be mapped into
objects which can then be mapped into
the database once you have defined the
data that you need to store you need to
Define endpoints through which this data
can be manipulated or queried
so I want to read comments
give me an API an HTTP API or FTP API
for All We Care the network protocol at
this point is not important but some
method by which I can send an electronic
signal from one place to our server and
our server can respond to that signal
with the data that they need so our
server is now encapsulating this data
as per the user requirement and defining
some endpoints which are called apis
so that external users can query and
manipulate our data we do this for every
feature that we have core features and
also optional or good to have features
usually a product requirement document
does not define optional or good to have
features these are all core features
which are required in the document the
good to have features will be probably
picked up in the next document so you
don't need to think of which features
are optional but you do think of which
features are most important as an
engineer
the second thing is you also have
certain engineering requirements when
you're creating
these designs sort of coming up with
some code you want to make sure that
none of your services fail if there is
an outage so for example if you have an
outage in India and your comment service
is in India then you don't want the
entire system to collapse we talked
about this a little earlier that you
have multiple servers spread across the
world to avoid a single point of failure
you may also have multiple servers in
India itself so if one Indian server
fails another one
picks up its responsibility
so here you might have some sort of data
duplication because of which the other
server is quickly able to pick up the
responsibility or you have some sort of
partitioning that 50 of the users are
going to this server 50 of the users are
going to another server so just 50 of
the users are affected under the common
and often missed out engineering
requirement is extensibility
which means it's not just about the
technical solution that you come up with
but also how easy it is to change that
solution
for example if you write code to send a
message to millions of users and you
need to make a small tweak to that code
because now you don't want to just send
it to 1 million users you also want to
check whether they have read those
messages so a read receipt
the problem with writing code which is
highly coupled with the feature is that
whenever there's a changing requirement
you have to put in a lot of effort to
redesign test and actually deploy that
code again
so you want your features your
engineering features to be extensible
for this you have to take out your
engineering crystal ball and gaze deeply
into it actually what you do is as an
experienced engineer especially you look
back at your past
um projects you you look back at things
that you have done you look back at
things that people have done uh you know
what the world is doing and based on
that combined knowledge you build a
system so that you can reasonably expect
it to scale and extend as requirements
change and as more and more users join
you finally this design needs to be
tested this is an important part of
system design which is not really
thought through in interviews but in the
real world when you have a system
is designed by let's say a senior
engineer that design has to be tested so
you run through a couple of requests
with edge cases with common cases
and you see whether these requests are
having a sensible flow in the system at
high level
the other thing that you can do is you
can use sophisticated tools to load test
this design you can have some sort of
capacity estimation to actually see
whether this design is feasible but
importantly you have to test this design
before you start getting into the code
okay let's recap with an example
let's say we have a live streaming
system
how would we go about designing this
requirements would be streaming video
processing video
sending video to multiple customers so
that is broadcasting uh not failing is a
requirement showing advertisements
allowing reactions showing disclaimers
or new splashes having graceful
degradation of video quality in case you
have low bandwidth allowing multiple
device support
and so on amongst these you see that the
product requirements are mainly showing
video to a lot of users
that's that's the major requirement and
also of course comments is a thing and
being able to react is a thing you may
also consider product requirements to be
showing a banner in case there's a
problem uh it is but uh the core
requirement of course is just showing a
video so I'll pick this feature first
this means that I have to capture video
from a source let's say which is
shooting at 8K
and I should be able to store it in some
place
in my server so that I can query it
later
in a live streaming system the later
part the query it leader is probably
milliseconds so I may not want to query
that data at all I may want to directly
stream it from the video camera on to
millions of people taking a step back it
looks impractical because if I'm
shooting at 8K
at very high quality
uh and this is raw footage uh sending
that much data to people on their mobile
phones is unreasonable
so yes I need to store it in some sort
of a database or a file system and then
I should be able to stream that or query
that out so that I can distribute to all
of my customers but I don't want my
customers to know exactly how I'm doing
this or I don't want them to know about
there's a change in implementation
tomorrow I want this to be a black box
so that they can pay me and relax they
they just hit an API and their problem
is solved of course I might give them
clients which are downloadable on the
app store which take care of all of this
API and querying also so that as end
users they can just enjoy watching an
event instead of thinking about how the
technical part of this is actually
happening these apis have well-defined
signatures you can tell that if I want
this video ID in a particular format
then I have to query a particular API
called get video which is going to be
returning me objects of type frames and
those frames are also well defined so if
you have ever written a program you know
that these these API signatures are very
similar to Method signatures
the only difference being that these
apis might be queried not through a
programming language but through a
network protocol like grpc HTTP FTP any
kind of protocol which defines exactly
how an electronic message is going to be
taken from one place and sent to another
and also how the response is going to
come back and how the behavior of this
interaction is going to be that is
defined by the protocol so this is great
we have a system which is storing some
data which is valuable to us because we
want to watch this event live
and
this data is going to be queried using
apis also these apis are going to be
tested beforehand so that you know the
the clients who are using this one
paying for this service are not
disappointed when they actually query it
as Engineers we have to think of various
various scenarios
what is the database which is stored in
your videos crashes
what if a particular firewall on the
internet starts blocking all of your
requests what if one of the services
that you have written in your entire
system one program one piece of code
starts misbehaving because you have you
know introduced a bug in it or there is
somebody who has maliciously entered the
system and changed the code in that
system we'll have to use some design
principles that we talked about earlier
this challenge may also be a feature
request like if you want the musician
who's playing in this live event to be
able to talk to their audience do a back
and forth with some audience members who
they select either randomly or based on
their activity
so you have to display those users to
this musician live and be able to
broadcast two parties to millions of
people out there so taking these
requirements let's try to design a live
streaming application so there's two
ways to approach this one is from
customers or our clients to our server
which is out there in different parts of
the world and then to our database which
may be again in different parts of the
world
that's one way to think and the other
way to think is from our database to our
server so what kind of data do I need to
store to enable my server
and what kind of apis do I need to
expose to enable my customers to be able
to use my product
both of these approaches are fine they
require different ways of thinking
though
when it comes to a data based approach
you will need to consider what kind of
data do you need to store and often
you'll be thinking of these
pieces of data as tables
so you need to store a video with an ID
the video has a name
it has a size and it has some data
that's one way to think
I prefer the other approach where
customers Define their problems which
are then
fulfilled using apis on the server
which are then fulfilled by storing some
sort of data in the server
in the database
and that data is then mapped onto tables
like so and so for this system this is
the approach that we'll be using
okay in our case customers are live
streaming customers
so they may be streaming from their cell
phones
or laptops
or the TV and we can't assume which
device is being used more often in
certain countries you'll have certain
devices being used
more there could also be a tablet of
course from which they are streaming
this video but you see that there are
multiple devices which need to be
catered to this is a front-end
UI design problem
system design is more to do with the
distributed systems backend part of
things
there is some system design involved
when it comes to API interactions and
how to store or cache data on the front
end but that is not what we are focusing
on here we are focusing on the back end
part of the system okay so these clients
need to be able to query our server in
real time so what does our server need
to have its apis are going to be
something like get video and you pass in
the video ID
and you pass in your device type
so I send you the resolution based on
your device type and you might have a
particular offset that you know I have
already seen the first 10 minutes of the
video show me everything after the 10th
minute if I have a video
API like this I also need to return
something so the return type could be
some frames some video frames let's say
each of these frames is 10 seconds long
so a single frame is what I sent back
such that it is of this video for this
device
and after 10 minutes so 10 minutes to 10
minutes and 10 seconds that frame is
picked up and sent to the client if you
know about API design you see that this
API is not well named get video means
you get an entire video but you're
returning a frame so maybe we can rename
this to get video free other thing is if
you are using a rest protocol uh get is
going to be defined in the request
itself so GED
over here is going to say that get me
video
is enough to say that you want a video
in our case like we said it's a frame so
maybe get frame or get video frame is
what we are looking at you notice that
Vimeo also has a similar API when it
comes to getting the next 10 seconds
YouTube uh also has an API which tells
you from which point to which point you
want to see the video I'll give you all
those things right so we have this
what else
you should be able to comment on the
video
okay so what you should be able to do is
you should be able to post a comment
again I'm using a well-known Concept in
rest post means you want to put
something in the server you want to
manipulate some data you want to add
some data to the server
so if I say post a comment with an ID
here I don't care about which device it
is coming from because the comment is
just data which has to persisted in the
server uh based on that I'm not going to
be you know changing my response or
changing the behavior which I'm posting
the comment so I don't need that I don't
need an offset but I do need the comment
data I need the author of the comment
I need the post on which this comment
was made so maybe the video on which
this comment was made so the video ID
and similarly for each requirement we
can expose apis which will
allow us to query and manipulate the
data as we want so that roughly defines
our server side capabilities
okay we haven't spoken about
anything uh in detail
we haven't talked about the network
protocols also that we have reduced but
roughly this is what it is okay now
let's go for the next part
which is the database side of this
what kind of data we need to store to
satisfy these apis
returning frames is something we want to
do storing comments is something we want
to do and also probably get those
comments so uh and you know to get video
frames we also probably need to put
video frames
what kind of database should we use
comments are rather simple you can store
this in an SQL database such that an SQL
table having an ID over here uh the data
of the comments or text
being stored as a problem the author
which is a foreign key to a user table
right so in a user table you have an ID
and this author is going to be mapped to
an ID over here along with that we have
a video ID so there's a video table also
which has an ID and some data
the video IDs are going to be mapped in
this way okay an example of this would
be
video id10 is over here this is a
cricket match video ID 11 would be a
musical event okay and this is a comment
table so for this cricket match a
comment was made in which
they said hey and the author was author
number one author number one happens to
be caught up
that's their username
so if you have to display all comets
in the front end for a particular video
what you want to do is you want to get
all of the comments in this table
for that video 10
then you want to get the data for that
user because you want to display the
username who has made that comment and
you also want to get some video data
because you have to display that on top
of the page where the comment was made
so in this way we are able to satisfy
our requirement of
posting comments posting video now
overall this system is complete
we have a system which uh can answer
queries okay this is
good enough to start with this diagram
is not incomplete it's very very
rough or high level there's nothing here
which is concrete nothing which is let's
say
useful when it comes to implementation
at this point in time we have a rough
idea of how we are going to be talking
to each other not what we are going to
use to make this happen
so let's get into those implementation
details
firstly
on the client side
is there something we need to do
yes
different apis
require different behaviors
posting a comment means that I'm posting
this once
and I'll be querying that comment maybe
soon but it's not like I need something
to keep happening I don't need
continuous updates on the comment those
notifications can be given periodically
to me
or maybe I don't need those
notifications at all
after a few months I just don't need
notifications on that comment
so you see over here you have
non-real-time Behavior
what about a video frame
when I ask for a video frame
I usually need to ask for the next video
frame immediately after that
so I'm watching a live video I asked for
a video frame I am sorted for the next
10 seconds in five seconds I'll be
asking the next video frame
so that behavior is different it's a
more continuous Behavior
Okay so
maybe we need to use different network
protocols to make this happen
what would I use for a comment I would
use
the most common Network protocol when it
comes to distributed systems which is
http
HTTP gives us the benefit that you have
a stateless server
you don't need to store any information
when you're handling a request
a stateless server is basically I have
no idea where you are from or what you
want Define everything in the request
okay goddessen wants the next 10 seconds
of video what do you mean by the next 10
seconds
is God of sand
Okay so
what should be there in the request is
here's God of sen this is his user ID
you can actually go and look it up in
your database
it's not the next 10 seconds that he
wants he wants the video from minute
number 10 to 10 minutes 10 seconds
okay that video length is also well
defined there is no concept of the next
point of view and the video ID is
mentioned it's not like gaurav wants the
next 10 seconds of the video he was
watching no I have no idea what video he
was watching you define which video
needs to be pulled up here you might
think that this is an obvious Point like
what's so special about defining
everything in the client itself it looks
a little tedious and stupid but doing it
is fine doesn't everyone do it
not necessarily uh when you ask for the
next 10 seconds of video for example
very often
as a client you know you don't know what
the next 10 seconds should be
take an example
give me the video at 10 minutes
so 10 seconds from 10 minutes okay
that's one chunk
let's say you make that request
and the server is taking time to give a
response now you come back and you say
give me the same video
because you didn't receive it in time
the server is going to look at that
request and serve you the same response
again the other approach to this would
be
the client making a request give me the
next 10 seconds
where next is known to the server
okay so here
the definition is not 10 minutes to 10
minutes and 10 seconds the definition
here is the next 10 seconds
the server is now going to take this
request
look at the user's current pointer and
then decide which 10 seconds to pull out
so in the first case it will take 10
minutes to 10 minutes 10 seconds in the
second case it's going to make
a decision to send you the video from 10
minutes 10 seconds to 10 minutes 20
seconds
what's the benefit the client didn't
need to know
which part of the video it wants to
watch
it lets the server handle it
it makes the overall Network more
efficient because the client is not
making duplicate requests and it makes
the client code a little more simple you
don't need to Define everything every
single time
United server figure it out
with context that's the difference
between a stateful and a stateless
protocol HTTP is stateless its benefit
is that the server is kept simple if the
server crashes there is no context or
memory that is lost in the server I mean
if you forget where the client currently
was pointing to then this is a serious
problem right you can go and store it in
your database instead and make a server
stateless therefore the protocol that
you are going to use HTTP can be
stateless the best part about this is
you can add new servers without any
issue you have no State being stored in
server so whenever a new server pops up
a new request comes with total context
in the request itself which you use
to query your data right what about
video frames uh do you want to query
video frames you want to get the next
one
what kind of a protocol will be nice
you can use http here also but a much
better protocol would be something which
is designed for video transmission
because in video you have to consider
some other parts
what happens if I have a mobile device
which does not have much resolution what
happens if I have poor bandwidth what
kind of video am I transferring if it's
a live streaming thing then the current
video is the most important video
what happened previously does not matter
anymore if I missed that packet if that
packet was dropped in a network
Let It Go
uh if it's a if it's a live streaming
lecture where you know there needs to be
full context to understand the next part
of this lecture then you probably want
to send it properly you want to send it
over a reliable Network and over a
reliable protocol
okay so if you wanted a reliable
protocol a TCP backed protocol is a good
idea if you want a real-time efficient
protocol then a utv-backed protocol is a
good idea so over here I'm going to use
a protocol like webrtc
here webrtc is a peer-to-peer protocol
so you actually are able to send video
from the server to the client certain
protocols have a client to server
expectation so the client is the only
person who can send data
who can make a request to the server the
server cannot send data by itself to the
client
okay so what I'm doing again here is
using a peer-to-peer protocol for the
video but for comments it's always going
to be client to serve
so you see that Network Protocols are
also important when it comes to
designing systems okay finally on the
server side what are some considerations
we have to take
similar to the
server side we have to think about how
are we going to talk to the server
but most database Solutions let's say
MySQL or postgres Define exactly how
you're going to be talking to the
databases
so this is a PCP backed protocol usually
but the protocol is defined well so we
don't need to think of that when it
comes to
talking to servers elasticsearch for
example has HTTP based protocol uh
Cassandra Amazon TV Amazon dynamodp uh
MySQL postgres all of them you know the
protocols have been defined
the problem then becomes which database
solution should we use
because
there's a ton of solutions out there and
they have trade-offs we could store data
in the mySQL database also but
it's going to be expensive
and it could be potentially very slow
also
so what is this video data it's
effectively a file so storing it in a
file system is not a bad idea
right and you don't want to build a file
system yourself so you want to use a
well-known file system solution for this
maybe hdfs
that's one solution you could also use
a video hosting solution like Vimeo
yeah it's off the shelf you can just use
it
you can use Vimeo by the way to host
depends also so it's best to mention
this in the system design uh requirement
like maybe an Enterprise solution from
you will take care of the entire thing
but if you can't do that if you can't
have a live streaming uh requirement and
you don't want to lose your job maybe
because then you go into Vimeo then uh
you can use a file system
like sdfs or S3
Amazon S3
the benefit of S3 or hdfs is that it is
cheap
it's easy to query and you can store
very large files inside it
okay in a database uh yes it's also it's
not cheap but it is easy to query and
you can store very large files inside
the capabilities that a database gives
you in terms of updating data or
acquiring data may or may not be very
relevant to you when you have a static
file which is a video file
your primary looking at low cost
when it comes to storing video Solutions
what about the user or the comment table
these two tables can have SQL solutions
back in them that's a MySQL or postgres
you may say that a comment is a complex
data structure every time you know a
requirement changes the common dfl also
needs to change
maybe you want to persist a lot of data
in the comment table per entry you want
to persist all the replies of the
comment also in the same entry so a
mySQL database or a SQL database is not
what you're looking for
you're looking for a nosql database
which is not ideal when it comes to
transactions or relational
joints
but you don't have that requirement
you're looking for scale when it comes
to comments you just want to persist
that data in a key value fashion so
that's no SQL
great this is a very rough idea of how
we are going to be
designing which is satisfying the
requirements of the system
and also defining the protocols or the
solutions that we'll be using to make it
possible for example we talked about
webrtc HTTP when it comes to network
protocols and when it comes to database
Solutions we talked about MySQL and you
know a file system a design can go in
more and more depth based on how
important that requirement is so doing a
recap we see that we have a system
a very rough blueprint even now which
talks about how our customers are going
to be accessing our apis and how those
apis are going to be accessing the data
in our database
the data in our database may be being
filled by customers like in Facebook
usually the customers are the people who
are filling the data or it may be filled
by an external service in a live
streaming system it's probably going to
be a really high deficient camera which
is going to be the recording the video
live and persisting to a database
okay the network protocol that you
probably want to look at is
rtmp real-time media protocol
which is a guaranteed protocol you don't
lose any data when you are
shooting video using this and the idea
is webrtc you might lose some data
that's okay it's the end user watching a
live stream uh they want data quick and
real but at the source of everything you
don't want to lose any data because
everybody else will lose the data if you
lose it at the source so a highly
reliable Network can be set up over here
you know high bandwidth expensive
Network because
that that video camera is really going
to need a high bandwidth expensive
Network to persist that amount of data
into your database and then this data
can be sent you're seeing that I have
skipped a lot of requirements you see
that I can't take this high quality data
and just send it broadcast it to
everybody on the planet what I'll need
to do is transform this data okay so now
what we are doing is we have looked at
at high level what the solutions are
going to be
and now really getting into the
nitty-gritties of Designing the system
so the first part of this is how do we
take this raw footage this data over the
high variable Network which comes to our
database our file system and convert it
into Data that we have to serve our
customers for ATP 720p so on and so
forth you can't serve 8K definition so
how do you do that there needs to be
some sort of a transformation service
over here
which is going to be taking this live
stream
and converting it into different
resolutions so
1080p which is full HD
you have 720p which is HD 480p which is
decent for quite a few mobiles and I
don't know if this
is something you want to do but if the
live part of your stream is really
important then 144p is also okay
because as long as people are getting
information and they're able to see
roughly what's going on
they're going to be happy uh sometimes
these resolutions are defined well in
the product requirement document itself
the PID because after speaking to
customers and getting their real
feedback you know which resolutions are
acceptable or tolerable for the customer
there might be some customers who asked
for premium 4K
transfer also
okay so that's that's fine I mean you're
watching it on TV then you probably want
to watch it at 4K okay
this raw video needs to be converted to
these resolutions
how do you do that so the first thing
you'll do is you'll break this video
into segments this entire raw video is
going to be broken into
segments of 10 seconds so you collect
video for 10 seconds
to chop it off you break that into one
segment and then you give it for
processing at Point number zero one two
three and four
so let's say you have these zero to four
which is five programs
which take the raw video
and convert it to different resolutions
so
if you pass in 144p
then a particular program picks it up
if you pass in 480p then another program
picks it up
uh maybe you have the same program which
is running in five concurrent pieces and
five threads based on the resolution
that you pass
it converts the video the 10 second
video footage into that resolution
similarly you can think of different
formats so if you have a device which is
an Android device
it probably has to see the video in a
different format okay it can't read all
sorts of video it has some formats which
are very defined inside it in the device
so it can read that format similarly
Apple devices might have a different
format so these formats Define how
you're going to read this piece of data
this video data which is going to be
sent over you through the network
common video format is 8.264
apart from 8.264 you might have your own
proprietary
formats let's say you have a format
which is more efficient than s1264 or
for your particular type of event a
music event you
research and you find that uh there's a
way to store video more efficiently so
this is more of a very large scale
problem like Netflix has its own formats
but uh if you're a small company h.264
is very good okay so different
resolutions
different formats we need to take our
raw video footage and convert this into
a combination of a resolution and format
so over here we use a design pattern of
map reduce
I won't go into too much detail of this
design pattern but the basic idea is you
can take one video split it into pieces
which is 10 seconds long and send it to
different servers
to get different outputs
okay you might have something else also
in the process apart from just
transforming the type of video maybe you
want to compress it here in the next
step that can be in step two uh the
servers being used here might be S3 S2
and S1 so you see S1 is being used here
and here S3 is being used here and here
so there is no uh there's no guaranteed
execution server that you have for one
part of the process any server which is
free will pick up a task
and execute it
whether it's compression or
transformation
again finally you get three different
outputs
which you can store in your database
so this would be the map reduce pattern
it's a very high level overview of this
it's almost a caricature of the
mapreduce pattern because there's no
reduce uh in this process over here but
uh have a look at this design pattern it
is useful when it comes to taking a
single piece of data or a data Lake and
converting it into the data streams that
you need next how is this data actually
going to go to the users who are looking
to view it so this data has to go over
here to the server right which is
exposing these apis of get put post when
you query this data
using a protocol you should be able to
get it we spoke about webrtc earlier
which is a peer-to-peer protocol and
it's really good for video conferences
because multiple people are streaming
video together
however in this case it's a broadcast
not a conference so we can take a step
back and say instead of webrtc we are
going to use a protocol which is more
suitable for streaming
there's
there's a couple protocols here also
the most popular one would be MPEG Dash
MPEG is a popular protocol Dasher stands
for dynamic adaptive streaming over http
which means that depending on your
bandwidth depending on the network that
you're on you're going to be able to see
high quality video or low quality video
for example you know you are you're
going in a car you're watching the video
at 1080p you enter a tunnel your network
is really really poor so you start
watching it at 144p
as a client you don't want to handle it
you want the network protocol to handle
it
it's defined in Impact Dash
other very similar protocol is hls this
is useful for iOS or Mac devices okay
and finally what kind of data do you
want to store on the server do you want
to store any data at all do you want to
make it totally stateless yes
statelessness is useful when it comes to
request serving uh and keeping context
for every user but
for some things you can keep some State
like when it comes to video you can
cache the last
10 minutes of video on your server so
anybody asking for video in the last you
know that video which is inside the last
10 minutes is going to get it from the
cache instead of you making a full
Network call to the database all the way
over here
you instead serve it from server itself
so you avoid this network call saving
time and bandwidth both so these are the
high level considerations that you have
when it comes to a system design like we
said this is a large scale distributed
system our assumption is that you have a
lot of users because of which this much
planning and this kind of a design makes
sense cost wise and Engineering effort
wise we mentioned that there needs to be
fault tolerance here there needs to be
performance here so you can use things
like CDN Solutions
so you can use content delivery Networks
to persist some static data and have the
clients actually pull the static data
from here web pages are a good idea you
can also have some video data posted on
the cgns in which case authentication
becomes a bit of a challenge because you
don't want everyone to be able to see
this data
and does the CDL do the authentication
for you do you
write some code
and then host it on the CDN which does
the authentication these are the
challenges that you have especially when
you're designing a large scale
distribute system where performance is
key okay so this is at a high level the
things we need to consider when we are
designing any sort of a system where the
requirements are defined maybe in a
product requirement document maybe it's
a startup so uh it's at a very you know
nascent stage there is no requirement
document you are directly talking to the
customers and and coming up with a
technological solution which is going to
satisfy the requirements the important
things to notice are that you
Define the requirements as abstract
Concepts like objects uh these objects
then need to be able to be manipulated
and queried using apis on your server
the data representations need to be
stored in databases
once this high level blueprint is done
we start thinking about what exactly do
we need
to make this system possible so what
protocols are we going to use what kind
of database Solutions can we use in some
cases you also think of what kind of
intermediate design pattern Solutions
you can use like you have load balancers
you have message queues these are all
design patterns and these have been
converted into tools by various
companies redis for example provides
caches load balancers and many other
things are also provided by Cloud
solution providers AWS
you want to use these already
well built well-tested Solutions instead
of rebuilding it yourself unless you
know the the trade-off in terms of cost
and performance is significant and it's
worth it finally once you have decided
on the tools
you think about the interactions of
these tools and the interactions of
these services
to meet your requirements so we thought
about how are we going to take a video
and show it to the user oh well we have
to transform that video we have to
convert it into different formats
otherwise it won't be visible in
different operating systems we then
thought about how we are going to stream
this video to the server we then thought
about how we are going to stream this
video to the client device
and finally we kind of touched upon
actually streaming the video through a
CDN solution instead of from your server
because maybe your server is in the US
and even if it is you know close to the
person who's streaming
you don't want your server to handle all
that load all of that load or for some
static content you want to be giving
that load away to well-known Solutions
like content delivery networks which can
be tied up with their isps you can have
a look at how Netflix does it here
another part of system design is low
level Design This is in contrast with
what we just saw which is high level
design where we took different
components of the entire system and
thought about how those components are
going to interact with each other using
network calls using apis and then you're
going to be sending data from one place
to another but lastly if you look at
these systems they own the business data
related to that service now what we are
going to do is take certain functions of
these services and try to code it out
which means we are going to go into much
more depth
so that we are probably going to lose
some breadth okay when you look at the
high level design of a system you are
looking at everything from how the users
will be interact ING with your gateway
the Gateway is going to be actually
sending these requests to your internal
Services the internal services are
looking at databases you can't code all
of this out uh even in you know at work
you can't just have this all in one
document one page so you take small
chunks of the system and you try to
elaborate on each Chuck
that would be the low level design the
core functionality of live streaming is
to be able to view a video
as a customer as a person who's paid
maybe it's a subscription maybe it's a
one-time purchase but what we are
looking at here is how does a user
fetch video view video and fetch more of
the video and continue doing so till the
video ends right we are not looking at
onboarding the video onboarding a movie
or you know how the live stream is going
to be moved from the source camera to
our system we are looking on the other
side the user side of how it's going to
be consumed by the users to do this we
again have two approaches one is to
think of the code in this start so if
you are an object oriented programming
language person you might think of what
kind of objects do I need to have in my
system how these objects interact with
each other is there any kind of
inheritance I have to take into
consideration but as earlier this is a
little difficult to think of unless the
requirements are extremely well
specified or they are so generic that
you have to look at the data that you
are storing first before you think of
the functionalities I would suggest you
think of the user so even over here we
think about
what are the actions that a user can
perform
so what I'll be doing is on my phone or
on my desktop I'll be scrolling to a
particular place to watch the video
okay so I'll be copying the video up to
a particular point that can happen I can
also click on Play From the Start so
start the video at the beginning at
times Time Zero uh both of these are
very close to each other so effectively
the the action is play video and
timestamp X
another functionality that I need is to
pause the video okay in which case what
do you do
do you continue fetching more segments
from the back end or do you stop
touching segments
so the behavior is dependent on the user
experience that you want to give if you
don't want to clog up their mobile with
the entire video while they have just
kept it you know in the background uh
then you have to be smart about it
probably the next 20 or 30 seconds or
one or two minutes can be buffered
into your device so that behavior also
has to be coded inside despite pausing
we go for the next two minutes of video
from the place that you have seeped
right now another important requirement
is that depending on your device the
video quality which is going to be
fetched is going to be either HD let's
say you're viewing it on a desktop or
ATP let's say for low resolution devices
and one final feature is
up to what point have you played a video
which means if you had a one hour long
video let's say there's a cricket match
between India and Pakistan and it's one
hour long and you have seen up to the
20th minute
if you log out and come back and want to
watch the same video we should start at
the 20th minute we should store that
somewhere so that you have a good user
experience
you might want to Cache the video like
we were doing earlier the next two
minutes you want to keep that buffered
so that you know you start playing
immediately when the user has come or
you may not want to do that you might
want to do that just for some videos
which have been recently watched the
older videos then can be kicked out of
the cache you see that what I'm
considering here are memory
optimizations
user behavior and API calling this is
largely what rule level design will mean
when it comes to interacting with
Services depending on your level of
seniority and depending on the use case
you might have issues of concurrency
latency
and throughput also come in here an
example use case will be the workflow
that we had for chunking and
transforming videos I'll leave that as
an exercise to you but there are cases
where you want to increase your
throughput to the maximum
so you don't really care that much about
latency you know how quickly do you get
those videos through the pipeline that's
not your concern you want to make sure
that your pipeline is continuously
functioning right uh another case is
where the moment a video comes in
the new video you want to respond to it
as quickly as possible with the
assumption that that video is really
important
so there's going to be some sort of
context switching over there okay I'll
leave that as an excise to you I won't
give you too many details but it's
interesting to think about how these
different low level design requirements
affect the code that we write similar to
what we did earlier we are going to take
a structured approach to solving this
problem the first tool that we like to
use is called a use case diagram
as the name suggests we think about what
are the use cases that we need to
fulfill for every user
for example you can see three actors in
this system an actor is a person who can
do actions
so an admin can do actions in our system
they can add videos maybe a videographer
is the person who can upload videos so
it may not be necessary that every video
which has been uploaded will be added to
the system before it gets added it has
to have some metadata added to it you
know what's a description what are the
timestamps uh what kind of video is this
how do you tag it so that might be taken
care of by an admin the videographer
shoots the video uploads it uh specifies
the quality and everything else so
that's a separate actor and a customer
the person who consumes the video we
said that this is the most important
person for us so this is the only actor
that we are going to be thinking about
let's get rid of these two actors we
mentioned that there are four things
that we want the customer to be able to
do let's note them down
the first thing is to be able to play a
video
from a timestamp okay
then comes another requirement which is
this is them coming back to the old
video that they watched partially and
they want to start watching again from
the laptop timestamp we also want to you
have the maximum quality
uh Allowed by Network and device so if
you're on a low quality Network that's
okay you know you low quality videos
also fine but if I'm on my home Wi-Fi uh
I want to see the best quality video
that I possibly can I've paid for the
subscription uh there's things which are
also happening in the background of
course like we said concurrency fault
tolerance throughput these are things
which the end user does not need to
think about uh you might say latency is
something that affects the user
it kind of does uh but we are not
looking into it we are assuming that all
of our
requests have to be answered within 10
seconds quickly enough uh and this
brings us to our next point we need to
continuously buffer uh our video right
so
have Non-Stop
play
when watching
videos
this is assuming of course that that
bandwidth is not messed up if your
bandwidth is messed up you can't buffer
so that's not a problem but if my
bandwidth is fine then for the next two
minutes I should be able to watch the
video
okay and this is the customer uh if we
can fulfill these requirements they're
going to be a happy customer
which matters a lot as an engineer
okay
these would be called use cases
right you can have many use cases some
of them are core use cases some of them
are not when it comes to system design
the expectation is that if there is a
PRD that has been given to you a product
requirement document usually it's just
on one use case right you add a feature
and each feature is important so we'll
take all of these and mark them as
reasonably important the next step is to
convert these requirements into classes
and objects
this is where things usually go wrong
when you look at the use case diagram
right it looks like everything is
to do with the customer View at maximum
quality Allowed by networking device but
is the customer actually doing that is
the customer saying that please give me
the best quality video no that is
obvious
that part is obvious so who's going to
handle that
if the customer is not going to handle
that part of the system
then the system has to handle that part
okay so there needs to be another actor
in this system but it's not a it's not
somebody who does actions like
physically
they're going to be interacting with
your system
so viewer maximum quality offered by uh
the network
who's going to handle that there needs
to be some sort of a controller or the
brains behind
how much video should you send
so I'll just call this the rate limiter
okay
sometimes the entire service
the entire functionality can be handled
just by using a tool so we offload the
problem to a tool or in our case what
would be ideal is
to use a network protocol which takes
care of this
depending on my device and depending on
my network requirements you take care of
the bandwidth an Adaptive bit rate
protocol is going to handle this HTTP
Dash will handle it so we'll assume that
this entire service which was going to
look at the user's requirements and then
offer them video at particular
bandwidths can be taken care of
by a simple protocol
so this weight limiter does not need to
exist uh instead whenever you're
connecting to our system it's going to
happen over HTTP Dash
right that is a pretty big deal uh one
entire use case taken care of just
because you know what tool to use now in
an interview scenario you might be asked
how does http Dash work exactly how does
it work internally for that you can
either read some papers which help you
learn the protocol internals uh database
interns are also very similar operating
system interns are also very similar or
you can guess
in which case you should probably
specify that hey I'm just guessing over
here but I think what's going to happen
in this adaptive Retreat resemble
exponential backup and TCP
now for the next bit
clear video from a timestamp
this means that every video needs to
actually store
corresponding timestamp for a particular
user
okay that can be done
we need to have an object here
our service which is video
server a video consuming service is
going to be used by end users
play a video from a timestamp
Okay so
this has to be taken care of by the
video consuming service
so that will be play video
for a user
and this is the video ID
okay so I'll just remove the
plane
put this and I'll also mention the
timestamp that has been passed here
you see that I'm still thinking in terms
of apis the clearer your apis are the
easier your lower level design will be
the more you think about how the users
or each feature is going to be
implemented uh using
the services that you have the easier
Your Design will be
okay
um go back to video and watch from
laptop timestamp this is quite
straightforward you have
seek
for this user and this video what is the
seek position so let's say we call it
get seek position but like we said if
you're using a
the rest API that you can just
you can mention in the method it's get
so that will send you back the seat
position uh it's it's best to mention
the return type also like I said
the clearer you make your API the better
it usually is so video frame will be
sent back here and similarly what will
be sent back here is
timestamp
so what's going to happen is when you
come back to a video which you have left
off you're going to first sync what is
the position
where you should go to so that will give
you a timestamp and then you'll say okay
play this video for this user from this
timestamp
all right
have non-stop play when watching videos
this is interesting we need to get
frames in future so
what do we do do we say play here or do
we say
video
okay
for a particular user
uh
kind of video
with a given timestamp
do you see that these two are very
similar
it says what this API is also going to
return you is a video frame
and you're going to stack these video
frames together and buffer them into the
video into the phone
so I see a very very close linking
between this API and this API
at this point you ask yourself
you know what does the product need is
play a different action from fetching
the future content
and here I'll make a decision
of yes it is different
it's strange to think of because they
are doing the exact same thing what
they're doing is there the user is
saying play me this video from this
timestamp
that's okay and the other one is that
the player the video player is saying
get me the video frame for this
timestamp
looks extremely similar but the business
use cases are very very different if the
user says get me a video from this
timestamp it means that they are
probably seeked to that position they
like what they saw their or they found
it exciting and they clicked on it so
it's very different Behavior compared to
hey get me the next two minutes of video
in the background
okay
that's one very important thing when
you're designing any API uh think about
who is using it what is it being used
for right and then think about the
common functionalities
so these two apis are very similar
on the server side what you would
ideally like to do is just
merge these two apis
you know the the client should figure
out by itself uh that what video frame
doesn't want to pick
so maybe you cut down on the apis that
you have to maintain uh by
replacing the current API of play
with what we have here
so maybe every time you play from a
particular point we should sign an event
to the backend service saying that this
is an exciting part of the video the
user actually came to this timestamp C
here and clicked on the video
okay you see that there is a seek API
which is primarily for uh when you have
left off a video so if you left off came
back and started watching from there
maybe it's not super exciting it's just
the place that you're leading off from
you you know you want to continue from
but during the video while watching it
if you came to a particular position and
started viewing
that requires an event that shows that
you know this part of the video is
sought after so it feels like you're
spitting hair here but from the side of
the business or from the side of
analytics they are very different use
cases from the side of engineering it's
the exact same behavior you know someone
asked you for 10 seconds of video you
give them 10 seconds of video but for
analytics or for the business
this part should be converted into a
trailer
this part is just for user experience so
it depends on you as an engineer I
personally would take this API
and I would see who's making this
request
so a flag would probably say that the
user made this request or the device the
mobile made the request for good
buffering and depending on that flag I
would then fire an event for showing
interest in this part of the video all
right so that is the use case diagram we
can now think about the class diagram
let's draw the class diagram out the
first class that we need is a video two
things that we need to store for every
class uh States and behaviors
states are data that an object needs to
perform behaviors
for example I'm speaking right now so I
need a throat I need a tongue I probably
need a brain to speak
and what I'm doing right now is teaching
so the behavior would be teaching while
the Theta that I need is my body parts
to actually work in tandem similarly you
might have a video which has certain
data that it needs so that would be the
bytes of the video
of lots of creams because we have been
using this term that's in every video
you might have some metadata like
who's the uploader of this video how
long is it what kind of tag do you want
to add so on and so forth
what operations can you perform on the
video
but you can
you can get a frame right that's that's
pretty much it
okay you can't add a frame after you've
added a video you can't do anything
apart from just getting a frame from a
particular point so that's a simple
class
you also have the class of user you see
that
I'm not focusing on the class diagram
so user has
a name
email
metadata around them but nothing else
really
the most important thing probably should
be an ID
in your case could be an email a video
also will have an ID
and for a user you can probably get
there
10 which brings us to the most exciting
class which is uh
what should be doing
okay so a watched video
is going to be an action by a user who's
basically watching a video so this needs
a video ID which video have you watched
who is watching it that is the user ID
any of the actions so that you can
refer to it later uh up to what time
stamp have they watched this video so
seek timestamp and coming back to the
use cases
we might want to buffer up to a
particular point but let's assume that
the client handles that the client knows
how long
how much we do you have buffered already
in the device
going back to a particular place is
possible because of the timestamp the
final class is video consuming service
this also requires a class to be
explicitly
shown here so that is video consuming
service
let's first Define the behaviors that
this class has so that is API one and
API 2.
and to do this it just needs a set of
watched videos
which will tell it which user has seen
what we do okay that takes kind of
our entire class you see this is a very
simple class diagram
what is more challenging actually is the
sequence diagram
okay how is a user going to watch the
video
so this would be called a class diagram
where we have defined what state and
what behaviors are possible for each
object in our system
fine
these two diagrams of a class and use
case are sufficient in most cases
however in some places where the
interaction is complex like over here
you need another diagram which defines
the sequence of actions in this case
it's not very clear how the user is
behaving these are the actions that they
can do okay
these are the things that you need to
store and the behaviors you need to
expose for the action to happen
that's also right what is the sequence
of actions what happens first what
happens second
that's not clear and for that you need a
sequence diagram so let us try doing
that
this is what you call a timeline
the y-axis basically is time but in
descending order so so you have three
timelines here one is that of a user a
user does certain actions
things happen to a video okay and the
video consuming service actually uses
the videos
current seek time to get the next frame
so this might not just be a video it
could be a video service which is
providing an API to consume the next
frame of the video
we'll see how this happens first the
user sends a message what message is
this right like we said earlier this is
going to continue to information
and the video information
foreign this is responded to by the
video consuming service immediately
because it knows up to what point has a
user seek the video so that is you
return a timestamp now the user is going
to make another interaction which is
play or get video frame right so give me
the video frame
as this user for this video after
timestamp and the tool I'm using here is
lucidchart as you can see if you use
tools it helps
instead of remitting the wheel or you
know doing it in a haphazard way
this is much better
the video consuming service cannot get
you the frame though
however it's best that the user
interacts with the video consuming
service so it could send a message to
the video service and say
uh get me the video frame
from a particular time
okay the important thing to notice here
is that
the video service has no idea
who the user is whether they're
authenticated or not to watch this video
and
it just gives you a timestamp okay I
could have taken this request and sent
it directly to the video service
okay and the media service could say
sure you know I don't care about what
who which user is uh is trying to access
this video just tell me the video and
the timestamp and I'll give you the
response but authentication would be a
bit of a problem
so that's the reason why I'm assuming
authentication is going to happen here
for every frame that you ask
and then the video timestamp
has been mentioned
I'm going to be sending back
a response of a video frame
I could also send back multiple frames
in the hope that you can use them uh
later but I'm assuming that the frame
lasts for 10 seconds and if you really
feel like you can send the request in
between and get another frame so it's a
single frame and
this is then
sent back
to the user
okay that's the interaction
for a while the moment you get a frame
you want to repeat this action
and so the data keeps flowing
uh very similar to how a TCP connection
Works actually uh initially you have
some sort of a handshake
right you get some initial information
set up the connection and then what's
happening is you're constantly pinging
one of the drawbacks that I can see here
in my diagram is that the video
consuming services are intermediary
there's so much communication happening
between the video service and the user
this is just wasting time I don't know
if that is worth it if just
authentication is
is worth completing our flow this much I
mean you can put some authentication
here in the video service itself
so you will save on
two Network calls
which is a lot
so yeah maybe I should just take this
put this here
and take this for this over here
right don't go into the video consuming
service
that's what we'll be doing in the code
so now we finally jump to coding uh
remember to use the diagrams that we
have made as a reference because most of
our thoughts and most of the
interactions are documented well over
there it would be a waste not to use it
the whole purpose of making these
diagrams is to take away the thinking
effort required by coding coding is
basically us
typing out or writing the things which
have been mentioned or thought through
in these diagrams
okay that will speed things and also
help you avoid mistakes so the first
class that we talked about is
a video class last video
the
state that we talked about is it has an
ID it has
frames
so maybe a set of frames here but then
the frames are also ordered so an array
of frames makes sense
and then some metadata so in our case
I'll just say meta Theta Json
of course in the real world you would
actually have the creator of the video
the uploader of the video and many other
parameters the length of the video
everything else
but we don't need that right now uh so I
just
create
a class
you see that an ID helps you create
classes much better
these classes that I'm creating are just
plain Java objects
you can use the same thought process for
C plus plus for C sharp and many other
languages any object or in programming
language if you're coding in python or
Scala uh it might be slightly different
right but the logic is very similar come
to the point of
Define things as objects and the
interactions between them
and finally Define the states and the
behaviors of every object and then quote
them out okay so this is largely
language agnostic this approach
you have a video which needs a thing
a frame is going to be a bunch of bytes
that's okay
and maybe it has a timestamp
so that is in
timestamp you also have a class of user
from the diagram
a user has a string ID
it has a string name
string email these are basically
metadata and we talked about some
behaviors that these classes need so
return of frame when someone says get
print
and which frame should we return
you should return the frame
which is being called for a particular
time stamp so you see our class diagram
and missed that now we can go back and
fix it
or we can fix it in code I would suggest
fixing it in both places because
if the documentation is up to speed it
helps
in timestamp
you can also have timestamp as an object
for you know making sure that the
integer is greater than zero and all
that all the validations that you want
but I'm just keeping things simple uh
pass under timestamp here we are going
to be iterating over the frames this can
be
improved of course but what you want to
do is you want to go over the frames
and return the timestamp
and return the frame only if
the timestamp of the frame
is less than the timestamp you have
asked for less than equal to
and there also has to be some sort of an
end time stamp so we can assume that
every frame is of 10 seconds in which
case
the start time is this this has to be
less than equal to and the end time
mentioned over here
plus 10 is greater than
or equal to this type
okay or rather greater than this Frame
belongs to this
if you don't get the frame
then you just return that
you can also throw an exception here
I would say throwing an exception makes
sense
because uh the meaning of an exception
is that I didn't
know how to react to this null would
mean that oh you get blank
so if a timestamp of
20 hours is sent for a video having just
one hour a blank frame is not exactly
what you want you want to say oh you're
out of bounds so
index out of the bounce exception
to be thrown here is going to be
okay
now there's another small problem I see
over here which is the magic constant of
plus 10. you don't really want to do
this it doesn't look good because
tomorrow if your frames get optimized
and can store 30 seconds of video then
you have to go and change it in the code
so you might have this in a constant in
the video itself let's say you know a
class constant so
public
static
it
frame time equal to 10
and then what you have is
if you need to make any change then you
make a change in a single place
but even that would not be suggestible
because this is something related to the
frame
so let's take that
put it in the frame class and then what
you have is
frame dot frame time
has to be this
but that is also
that's fine uh it's good there's just
one
data point for the entire class all of
your frames have the same amount of
frame time
it could be different
it could be that these frames uh some
frames are really high quality there's a
lot of movement over there so it's not
even 10 seconds long it's just two
seconds long and some frames are you
know like this coding frame over here
you can store 10-15 seconds of video
because there's not much happening over
here there's not any face moving or
something so I'll just take this
and I'll leave it to the object not the
class but the object so it does not
become a Class Property which is going
to be for every object it is defined by
each object so n timestamp
and then this becomes start time
all right so this is this is better I
don't need to say I don't need to
mention start timestamp I just say n
times timestamp has to be greater
okay this is much more flexible code
this is what will set you apart from
just a coder you're going to be a
engineer then
okay so now we have
a user uh you can get their ID so this
is
not really
related to what we are doing but that's
okay
in
get ID
and return yeah
okay the next class is more interesting
there's watch the video
which is a class
here we have the ID
of this action we have the video ID
we also have the user who's actually
watching this video
who's doing this action
and we have a seek Bank tax so that is
seek time okay we mentioned that there's
going to be
a method could get CPAC
important to note is that apis having
rest
have the keyword get inside them often
like you can
mention that you're posting something or
getting something but the objects here
can have a get of their own because you
don't exactly know what's happening
right it's not a HTTP API here it's it's
a Java
object so you can see time makes more
sense here
so this defines everything uh except for
the last couple of behaviors which uh
actions by a user or actions by a system
so the video consuming service
show me the seek time this is going to
be a public
it seek time
return
for this watched video
seek time had
a user ID and a
video ID
let's assume that watched video
is a database column
and once you have this watch video what
you want to do is you want to get this
10 and return that
okay so uh
for this to work
we need to have a database
which we are going to create as a dummy
object
okay
let's create that
and turn on
okay this is great yeah it gives you the
seek time and then finally
the other API that we looked for is
class
video service
so the final class is going to be using
a file system let's say
because videos are usually stored in the
file system
let's define that class this class
fight system
okay now there's a public method
similar to the previous service which is
going to be returning a frame
and that is get frame
for a particular video
with a video ID
and
a Time stack
okay and how's the interaction going to
happen we first need the video
so let's say our
file system
gets us a video
with this video ID
once you have the video you need to
return
the frame
corresponding to this timestamp
and that's it
that's pretty much it you have something
backing your services some sort of
database all file system uh once you
have them persistent you can always get
to them
and pull data from them once these
systems are being backed by a database
then you can actually manipulate this
data that you have by exposing apis and
the best way to manipulate the data is
to abstract them out into objects which
have their own State and behavior so the
code is simplified and you can reuse a
lot of the behaviors for different types
of use cases
this would summarize the low level
design process
all right then that's a reasonably well
detailed Introduction to System design
if you want to look at more videos on
system design there's a free section
that I have on interview ready which is
all about the design patterns and the
basics of system design load balancing
rate limiting uh sharding and you know
scaling
and if you want a more advanced version
of system design I have a paid section
in that same course
I would suggest go ahead and check out
the free resources first if you really
like it and you think that you know it's
time to level up go for the paint
section all the best